we're back running a little late Dick
Clark is setting up his booth in Times
Square so we should want now here to
present the Award for Best Foreign
Language Film please welcome a survivor
of one of Hollywood's longest marriages
miss Sharon Stone
the category is foreign language film of
the year with entries from 44 countries
throughout the world these five films
from Germany the Netherlands Brazil
Spain and Russia were judged by a
special panel to be of exceptional merit
and these are the nominations from
Germany
beyond the silence Karolina link from
the Netherlands character Mike von Dean
from Brazil four days in September Bruno
burrito from Spain secrets of the heart
Moncho Ottoman giri's from Russia the
thief
Pavel Chuck rye
and the Oscar hi dad I hope you're
feeling better and the Oscar goes to the
Netherlands for character accepting the
award
like Manny
this is a third Academy Award for the
nether
ah okay Sharon it's it's just you know
another crazy Dutch director you know
the film is character it opens next
Friday I'm not going to advertise it
this ought to tell you this ought to
tell you that it probably has you know
like damn stunning subtitles
ah three three guys who over a period of
the last two years really build my
character yes you're signaling to me to
be fast I'll be fast
bill my character were my great and
wonderful handsome producer allowance
Hill's my young talented actor fetch
awfully wet and the legendary yon
declare he's really Belgium's Titanic
he's III will salute everybody my crew
and my cast was watching this at home
Shelvin veld and a lot of coats Sony
Pictures Classics the Academy and as a
personal note my dear friend come from
Weber the calling I just know you're
smiling down on me now man look what I
got
yes